bonsoir benoît muracciole merci de
répondre à nos questions vous venez de
publier un communiqué intitulé le
gouvernement français fait tilt don de
30 rafale à l'egypte pourquoi posez vous
une telle question qu'on se pose cette
question parce que lors du premier
contrat qui a été signé en 2015 entre le
gouvernement français le gouvernement
égyptien
le ce contrat avait été assurée par la
coface qui obtient d'un organisme donc
quitte notamment tenu par l'état et qui
est là pour pallier justement au
financement de contrats passés en
international et jusqu'à maintenant dans
les questions que l'on a pu poser auprès
des autorités quand elles nous recevez
des ja eh bien nous n'avons jamais eu de
réponse ferme sur le fait que l'egypte
le gouvernement égyptien avait commencé
à payer les mir 1 les mirage et rafale
la frégate fremm et les deux mistral qui
avait été revendue donc l'egypte allait
pourtant on parle quand même d'un
contrat de 4 milliards d'euros 1
oui bien sûr les évaluations d'ailleurs
bon ce serait intéressant de savoir un
petit peu plus précisément c'est
toujours très difficile à savoir
qu'elles sont là quelle est la
répartition entre mba et puis
l'avionneur dassault mais ce qui est
assez extraordinaire
c'est la déclaration de madame la
ministre par lit quand elle dit que la
france est fière d'avoir un partenariat
avec l'egypte je vous rappelle que el
sissi est accusé de crimes contre
l'humanité contre sa propre population
en egypte où la torture est quasiment
systématique dans les commissariats
contre ses opposants
également deux lors de la répression
contre les les promos rssi
il y a maintenant de cela quelques
années et puis il intervient également
contre le travail des nations unies en
libye auprès du général haftar lui aussi
responsables de crimes de guerre
l'aviation égyptienne a également
bombardé des civils en libye
susceptibles d'être qualifiées de crimes
de guerre et enfin pour couronner le
tout l'egypte fait partie de cette
coalition qui intervient dans les gares
ou yémen depuis six ans la situation
la crédibilité à la plus terrible dans
le monde selon les nations unies
et nous avons sorti rafael et vont être
utilisées contre la population yéménite
prochainement c'est ce que vous êtes en
train de dire non n'a pas l'assurance
on n'a pas l'assurance que ce matériel
précisément sera utilisé dans pour
perpétrer des crimes contre l'humanité
notamment donc au yémen mais ce que l'on
sait c'est que les deux lycéens des deux
mistral
je crois que c'est le nasr qui était en
mer rouge et qui participe au boulot
puces et que le blocus de notre point de
vue l'année disent qu'ils ont fait dans
notre rapport fait partie des crimes
contre l'humanité donc c'est assez
terrible de voir et la ministre des
armées revendiquer simplement que la
france viole ses engagements
internationaux dont le traité sur le
commerce des armes
mais pourtant on l'a vu sur son tweet la
ministre des armées florence parle et se
félicite que les armées française et
égyptienne oeuvre ensemble contre le
terrorisme
oui il ya toujours cette question là
d'abord il ya pas deux il n'y a pas
d'accord international sur la notion de
chrétiens bien les corps est un monsieur
sur ce que sont des actes de terrorisme
donc est ce qu'on peut penser que le
fait de bombarder des civils de
participer à un blocus de
d'ordonner des tortures quasi
systématique dans les commissariats est
ce que l'on peut considérer ça comme des
actes de terrorisme
je suis assez d'accord donc jeu il ya
effectivement des actes de terrorisme
des groupes de groupes armés non
étatiques et que peut-être peut-être que
l'égyptien l'armée égyptienne de combat
mais comme elle participe comme ce pays
ce gouvernement un pas le pays mais le
gouvernement participe également à des
actes de terrorisme d'état eh bien la
france ferait bien de regarder tout
quelles sont ses engagements
internationaux le gouvernement français
serait bien de le regarder
c'est pour ça que action c'est que l'été
éthique républicaine appels d'urgence et
une enquête parlementaire afin de
connaître les tenants et les
aboutissements de ces contrats est de
savoir justement vérifier s'ils
respectent bien les engagements et inde
et chine la france le président al sisi
aurait souhaité garder le contrat secret
pourquoi une telle opacité
si elle est avérée pourquoi confirmé
aujourd'hui la transaction alors là ils
ont pu soit aujourd'hui le plus parce
que maintenant voilà une fois que
disclose a fait un travail formidable
d'ailleurs de sortir cette information
c'était difficile de la caf
d'autant que les gens qui étaient autour
de ce contrat sans doute commencer à
pouvoir parler que la formation allait
sortir bientôt
mais c'est pas du tout sûr que ce soit
le 6 6 qui demandait le secret la france
est tellement le gouvernement français a
tellement ont des contrats qu'ils
passent quand même invraisemblable
nous sommes dans un pays qui était jadis
le pays des droits de l'homme et nous
soutenons des régimes qui perpétue dans
le monde des crimes de guerre et des
crimes contre l'humanité ici c'est quand
même nous sommes sous 21e siècle cette
impression
cecily pression formation disclose qui
est à l'origine de ces révélations
n'avait pas
divulguer cette information quelles
auraient été les conséquences enfin
toute façon le trait sortie maintenant
avec le travail des journalistes
d'investigation notamment le travail
on l'a vu avec mediapart avec la
corruption en direction de toujours
d'assaut cet curieux toujours mbd a aidé
à ceux qui sont engagés dans des
contrats où il ya la corruption ou alors
quand les gens sont parce que quand je
dis là le gouvernement français ne va
pas être payé c'est à dire nous
contribuables français qui selon nos
informations en ce moment payons les
rafales et la frégate ainsi que les
mistral
enfin donné à l'egypte les entreprises
elles quand même de ramasse de l'argent
on voit puisque dans dans le fait que
dassault avait eux avaient déjà récupéré
cet argent puisque c'est l'argent c'est
les premiers rafale qui ont été livrées
à l'egypte elle avait été livré sur des
comptes en comptes engins de l'armée
française donc laissez entreprises se
font énormément d'argent et quand elles
disent qu'elles créent de l'emploi
elle crée de l'emploi mais on peut
penser qu'aujourd'hui créer de l'emploi
dans une crise sanitaire comme l'on
connaît aujourd'hui qui est depuis la
seyne l'avènement de la vème république
est à ce jour inconnue
eh bien on pourrait mettre de l'argent
dans les hôpitaux par exemple dans le
fait d'aider les soignants à vivre
correctement de dd tout les gens qui
sont des situations extrêmement de
violations aux droits de l'homme les
droits économiques sociaux et des droits
sociaux économiques et culturels sont
des droits de l'homme à part entière
donc ça fait beaucoup de violations pour
un même gouvernement
merci madame ou racial d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le président de l'acsel association
action sécurité éthique républicaine et
auteur du livre
quelles frontières pour les armes aux
éditions pedn